This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When it comes to sports, the uniforms matter a lot. Jerry Seinfeld famously said. Although team loyalty is a kind of hard thing to justify in the end. You know, I love the Giants, but when you think about it, who are the Giants? You know what I mean? You know what I mean? I mean, it's just, it's different guys. Every year it's who are the giants? You know what I mean? You know what I mean? I mean, it's just, it's different guys. Every year it's different guys, right? Teams will move from city to city. The players come and go, they get traded, they retire, they leave via free
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。说起体育运动，制服非常重要。杰瑞·宋飞曾有一句名言：尽管从长远来看，对球队的忠诚其实很难找到合理的解释。你知道的，我爱巨人队，但仔细想想，谁是巨人队？你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，这只是……这是不同的人。每年都是谁是巨人队？你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，这只是……这是不同的人。每年都是不同的人，对吧？球队会从一个城市搬到另一个城市。球员们来来往往，他们被交易，退役，通过自由球员身份离开，
agency, but you keep rooting for those colors in that logo and that uniform. You're rooting for clothes when you get right down to it. It's the same outfit. It's the same I'm rooting for an outfit. That's where it's come down to. I want Mike's team's clothes to be the clothes for me in the city. That's not so bad either. There's nothing really wrong with that. It's laundry. We're rooting for swimming about laundry here.
但你依然支持那些颜色、那个标志和那件制服。说到底，你支持的其实是衣服。这就是同一套行头。这就是同一套——我在支持一套衣服。事情最后就变成了这样。我希望迈克的球队的衣服能成为我在这个城市穿的衣服。这其实也没那么糟。这也没什么真正不对的。这就是洗衣房。我们在这里支持的其实是关于洗衣房的事。
And the measure of this, according to Paul Lucas, the creator of Beauty Watch, a website devoted to the obsessive study of athletics aesthetics is this. I'm a passionate New York Metz fan and I really, really hate the New York Yankees, but if the entire Metz team, 25 guys, is traded even up for the entire Yankees team, 25 guys, today, who do I root for tomorrow? And to me, the answer is obvious. It's a no-brainer. I root for whoever is wearing the Metz uniform, no matter who it is, even if it's a bunch
根据专注于痴迷研究田径美学的网站Uni Watch的创始人保罗·卢卡斯的衡量标准，情况是这样的。我是纽约大都会队的忠实粉丝，我真的、真的很讨厌纽约扬基队，但如果大都会队的整个球队，25个人，今天直接和扬基队的整个球队，25个人，做一换一的对等交易，明天我该支持谁？对我来说，答案显而易见，这根本不用动脑子。我支持任何穿着大都会队制服的人，不管他是谁，哪怕是一群
of guys who are wearing the Yankees uniform the day before. So the identities of the players are almost irrelevant. What we root for is the uniform. And that is an unusually strong form of brand loyalty, because if I like say a certain brand of cereal, let's say I like Cheerios, well I identify with the box and the logo and the colors and all that the package design but I also presumably like the product and if I find that the quality of the product has changed you know if it doesn't taste good anymore
前一天还穿着扬基队制服的人。所以球员的身份几乎是无关紧要的。我们支持的是制服。这是一种极其强烈的情感品牌忠诚度，因为如果我喜欢某种麦片，比方说我喜欢Cheerios（喜力奥），嗯，我认同盒子、标志、颜色和所有的包装设计，但我也可能喜欢这个产品，如果我发现产品的质量变了，你知道的，如果它吃起来不再美味，
or if some aspect of it if it doesn't stay crunchy and milk or whatever I may give it one or two more tries based on my brand loyalty, but eventually I will leave that brand. I will abandon it if I find that the quality is no longer there. But in sports, the content of the product and the quality of that content, meaning the players, is changing all the time. You can be really good one year, really bad.
或者如果它的某方面——如果它在牛奶里泡久了不再酥脆或者别的什么，我可能会基于我的品牌忠诚度再给它一两次机会，但最终我会离开这个品牌。如果我发现品质不再，我会抛弃它。但在体育运动中，产品的内涵和内容的质量，也就是球员，一直在变化。你可能一年表现极好，一年表现极差。
The next year your roster can turn over. So the content of the product is constantly in flux, but we stay loyal to whoever is wearing that uniform. And that is, and usually, to my mind, it's a unique form of brand loyalty. There's nothing else like it in our consumer landscape. Like Paul Lucas, my friend Jesse Thorn also obsesses over baseball uniforms, although he didn't make a career of it. He has another job. I'm Jesse Thorn. I'm the owner of MaximumFun.org
第二年你的球员阵容就会大换血。所以产品的内涵一直在变动，但我们对穿着那件制服的人的忠诚度却始终如一。在我看来，这是一种独特形式的品牌忠诚度。在我们的消费环境中，没有其他东西能与之相比。就像保罗·卢卡斯一样，我的朋友杰西·索恩也对棒球制服有着痴迷，尽管他并没有以此为生。他有另一份工作。我是杰西·索恩。我是MaximumFun.org的老板，
and the host of the NPR show, Bullseye. There are certain things about a uniform that serve a purpose by being uniform. They help the players identify each other. They help us rally behind our team, they give us something cool to buy, but there are certain things on a uniform that aren't uniform. Things that a player can choose. And the number of things that a player can choose are very, very small.
也是NPR节目《靶心》（Bullseye）的主持人。制服的某些特质通过保持统一而发挥着作用。它们帮助球员互相辨认，它们帮助我们团结在我们的球队身后，它们给我们提供很酷的购买选择，但制服上也有一些并不统一的东西。那是球员可以自主选择的东西。而球员可以自主选择的东西数量非常、非常少。
I mean, it was a big controversy when I was a kid, when Ken Griffey Jr. shagged balls in the outfield during batting practice with his baseball hat on backwards. It's a big controversy now when a baseball player wears his cap brim totally flat in what you might call the hip hop style as opposed to curved kind of like, is that what you mean? Yeah, well, I mean, they literally make a device that you can buy at the sporting good store or order via mail order that will give you quote unquote the perfect curve to your brim and I mean I remember as a little
我的意思是，当我还是个孩子的时候，这曾引起过轩然大波：当时小肯·格里菲在打击练习时，反戴着棒球帽在 outfield（外野）接球。现在，当棒球运动员把帽檐压得完全平直——也就是你可能称之为嘻哈风格，而不是弯曲的那种——这同样会引发轩然大波。就像，你是这个意思吗？是的，我的意思是，市面上甚至有一种专门的装置，你可以在体育用品商店买到，或者通过邮购订购，它能赋予你所谓的帽檐“完美的弧度”。我的意思是，我记得小时候，
eager obsessing over getting the brim of my hat to curve exactly right and I was not the only one. We had Jesse Thorn talk with Paul Lucas of UniWatch and he discovered that Paul also zeros in on the subtle expressions of individuality on a baseball player's uniform. I'm always very alert for any glimpse of the underside of a player's cap brim, because over the years, the color of that element, it's called the under brim or the under visor, has changed. When I was a kid, they were green, then they changed to gray for most teams, and now they are
我曾热切地痴迷于把我的帽帽檐弯出恰到好处的弧度，而且我不是唯一一个这样的人。我们让杰西·索恩与Uni Watch的保罗·卢卡斯进行了交谈，他发现保罗同样会密切关注棒球运动员制服上那些微妙的个性表达。我总是对窥探球员帽檐下方的任何一丝痕迹保持高度警惕，因为多年来，这个部位的颜色——被称为帽檐下侧或下遮阳板——一直在改变。当我还是个孩子的时候，它们是绿色的，后来对大多数球队来说变成了灰色，现在它们
mostly black, and some players will write something on the under-brim. Fewer players do it now, now that they're black, because you have to use like a white or a silver sharpie. Back when they were gray, players could just use any old pen, and players would write unusual things there. Inspirational messages with the names of their children or whatever the case might be. And that always, to me, was an interesting, sort of, stealth area of the uniform world, with a universe, as I like to call it. The other thing I'm kind of... You like that?
大多是黑色的，有些球员会在帽檐下侧写些字。现在这样做的人越来越少了，既然它们是黑色的，因为你得用白色或银色的记号笔。当年它们是灰色的时候，球员们随便用什么旧笔就行，他们会在那里写一些不寻常的东西。带有他们孩子名字的励志寄语或其他类似的内容。对我来说，这总是制服世界里一个有趣的、某种程度上的隐秘地带，就像我喜欢称之为一个宇宙。另一件让我觉得……你喜欢这个吗？
Because they're continuity in the universe. But when you get to baseball uniform, I fish in atos like Paul and Jesse together in conversation. There is one area of the baseball uniform that they truly geek out about, the intersection between the pant leg and the sock. Basically, the whole area below the knee, and it's the least legislated, least regulated, and really least uniform part of the uniform.
因为它们在这个宇宙中具有延续性。但当你谈到棒球制服时，我把像保罗和杰西这样的人聚在一起交谈。棒球制服中有一个领域是他们真正为之疯狂的，那就是裤腿和袜子的交界处。基本上就是膝盖以下的所有区域，这是制服中最不受法规限制、最少受到规管、也确实最不统一的部分。
Even though baseball teams have been historically named after the color of their socks, there is no rule governing the length of the uniform. Even though baseball teams have been historically named after the color of their socks, there is no rule governing the length of the pants. Or whether or not you will actually see those socks. And that has really changed in the last generation. And it's changed a particularly a lot over, you know, the last century or so. Early baseball uniforms had essentially knickers.
尽管棒球球队历史上一直以袜子的颜色命名，但并没有关于制服长度的规则。尽管棒球球队历史上一直以袜子的颜色命名，但并没有规则规定裤子的长度。或者你是否真的能看到那些袜子。这在过去的一代人中发生了巨大的改变。在过去的一个世纪左右的时间里，这种改变尤为巨大。早期的棒球制服基本上是马裤。
And what do you wear with knickers? You wear stockings. And that's what early baseball uniforms were. And over the course of the 20th century, those knickers started getting longer and longer. And they started drooping a little lower and a little lower. And they went to mid-caf and then lower-caf and then a little lower. And now we have so many of the players who wear their pants all the way down to their shoe tops like footy pajamas. And then you have a handful of players like, say, Alex Rodriguez and Curtis Granderson and
你穿马裤时会搭配什么？你穿长袜。这就是早期棒球制服的模样。在整个20世纪的过程中，那些马裤开始变得越来越长。它们开始一点点向下垂，先是到了小腿中部，然后是小腿下部，接着更低。现在我们有太多的球员把裤子一直拉到鞋口，就像连脚睡衣一样。然后你还有少数几个球员，比如亚历克斯·罗德里格斯、柯蒂斯·格兰德森和
Etro Suzuki who like to hike their pants up high. So there are a minority, but there is a faction of players who do that, but there's no uniformity to it. And I think it's a shame or even a tragedy that we've got these players who wear the pants all the way down to the shoe tops because when you cover up the socks, you're basically dishonoring baseball's hosiery heritage. So let's break it down. Today baseball pants are stretchy polyester.
铃木一朗，他们喜欢把裤子高高拉起。所以他们是少数派，确实有一派球员会这么做，但这没有任何统一性。我认为，我们有这些把裤子一直穿到鞋口的球员，真是一种耻辱甚至是一场悲剧，因为当你遮住袜子时，你基本上是在玷污棒球的长袜传统。让我们来详细拆解一下。今天的棒球裤是富有弹性的聚酯纤维。
They used to be wool flannel. So the pants that they have now, you can wear them kind of tighter loose and you can wear your pants at a variety of different lengths. So they can go down all the way to the top of your shoes and in fact some players have gone so far as to have a strap that goes underneath their shoes to keep it from showing any sock at all. You can wear your pants up sort of at the bottom of your calves, which shows a little bit of sock. That's probably what most players do, and they just kind of let them set there. You can wear your pants up all the way over your calves at the top of your calves, like they were, you know, sporting pants from the early part of the 20th century, you know, like they were bricks or plus tubes or plus floors. And if you wear your pants in that style
过去它们是羊毛法兰绒的。所以他们现在穿的裤子，你可以穿得紧一些或松一些，你还可以把裤子穿成各种不同的长度。所以它们可以一直垂到鞋子的顶部，事实上，有些球员甚至不惜使用一条从鞋底穿过的固定带，来防止露出哪怕一点点袜子。你可以把裤子向上拉到小腿底部，这样会露出一点点袜子。这大概是大多数球员的做法，他们就让裤子自然垂在那里。你可以把裤子一直拉过小腿，提到小腿的上部，就像你穿的是……你知道的，20世纪初期的运动裤，你知道的，就像灯笼裤或马裤一样。如果你以这种风格穿着裤子，
with the bottoms all the way up to your knees, you can either wear solid colored socks, you can wear socks with a stripe up the side that's meant to simulate a stir-up sock, or you can wear actual stir-up socks. Of these choices, stir-up socks are the ultimate in baseball, hosary for the diehard old school fans. If you need help picturing a stirrup,
裤脚一直提到膝盖，你可以选择穿纯色袜子，可以穿带有侧面条纹、旨在模仿蹬脚袜的袜子，或者你可以穿真正的蹬脚袜。在这些选择中，蹬脚袜对于铁杆老派球迷来说是棒球长袜中的极致。如果你需要想象一下蹬脚是什么样的，
they're basically two layers of sock. There's a bottom layer that's a normal old sock, but there's also an exterior sock that's a different color. But the bottom of that sock is just a strap that goes underneath the arch of the player's foot. The idea behind stirrups goes back about a century. Baseball pants used to be just knickers and you would wear stockings with them.
它们基本上是双层袜子。底层是一双普通的旧袜子，但还有一层不同颜色的外层袜子。不过这双袜子的底部只是一根穿在球员足弓底下的带子。蹬脚袜的设计理念可以追溯到一个世纪前。过去的棒球裤只是马裤，你得搭配长袜穿着。
But in the early days of baseball, baseball was a pretty rough and tumble game. Players would often get spiked and there were some players like the Great Hall of Famer Thai Cobb who would famously sharpen their spikes so that when they slid into second or third base, they would try to cut up the infielder. And if you got spiked in the shin,
但在棒球运动的早期，棒球是一项相当粗野激烈的运动。球员们经常会被钉鞋踩伤，有些球员，比如伟大的名人堂成员泰·柯布，出了名地会把钉鞋磨得极其锋利，这样当他们滑向二垒或三垒时，就会试图划伤内野手。如果你被钉鞋踩到了胫骨，
you'd get cut in your stockings and the fabric dies in those days. We're not color fast. And so if you got spiked, die from your stockings could get in the wound and you could get blood poisoning, or so was the thinking. I don't know if there are any documented cases of players who actually got blood poisoning. And so someone got the idea and we don't know who, some great hero who deserves a statue, you know, the statue to the great unknown stirrups innovator, that if you wore an undersock, an extra layer of sock, you would have an extra layer of protection, a sanitary layer of protection. And so this undersock became known as a sanitary, or a pair of such socks became known as sanitaries or sannies.
你的长袜就会被割破，那个年代的织物染料并不是固色的。所以如果你被踩伤了，长袜上的染料就会渗进伤口，你可能会得败血症，大家当时是这么认为的。我不知道是否有任何有据可查的病例表明有球员真的因此得了败血症。于是有人想出了一个主意，我们不知道是谁，某个值得一座雕像的伟大英雄，你知道的，向伟大的不知名蹬脚袜创新者致敬的雕像：如果你穿一双内袜、一层额外的袜子，你就会多一层保护，一层卫生的保护层。因此，这双内袜被称为卫生袜，或者这类袜子被称为“sannies”。
And then the overstocking, well, they didn't want you to have to wear the stocking over the undersock because now you'd be wearing two pairs of socks and your shoes wouldn't fit anymore. And so they decided to cut out the foot area of the overstocking and create this little stirrup opening. And that's how baseball stirrups were born. And originally, that opening was tiny. It was just enough for your foot to fit through.
至于外层长袜，嗯，他们不想让你非得把长袜套在内袜外面，因为那样的话你就要穿两双鞋，你的鞋就穿不下了。于是他们决定剪掉外层长袜的足底部分，创造了这个小小的蹬脚开口。棒球蹬脚袜就这样诞生了。最初，这个开口非常小。刚好够你的脚穿过去。
And almost immediately, players began pulling it and stretching it higher. And so more and more of an opening appeared and that exposed more and more of the sanitary undersauk, which was usually white. So you started having this sort of interplay of color of the ever widening opening of the colored stirrup and the white undersauk and by the 1960s there were players like Frank Robinson of the Baltimore Orioles who were actually cutting the bottom part of the stir-up,
几乎立刻，球员们就开始拉扯它，把它拉得更高。于是出现了越来越大的开口，这就露出了越来越多的白色卫生内袜。到了20世纪60年代，出现了一些球员，比如巴尔的摩金莺队的弗兰克·罗宾逊，他们实际上会剪掉蹬脚袜的底部——
the part that looped under your foot, and adding more fabric to it. So that they could pull their stir-ups even higher, higher than the manufacturer had intended. While stir-ups may have had this functional origin, they quickly lost that, and they just became incorporated into the visual language of baseball.
也就是绕在脚底的那部分，并给它缝上更多的面料。这样他们就能把蹬脚袜拉得更高，高得超出了制造商原本的设想。虽然蹬脚袜可能有着这种功能性的起源，但它们很快就失去了这一功能，并直接融入了棒球的视觉语言之中。
And I think for many people, myself included, it's what we think of when we think of a baseball player. It's interesting to note that in the pages of the New Yorker, the Weekly magazine, they run a lot of cartoons that are baseball themed, and their cartoonists almost invariably depict baseball players wearing stirrups, even though most actual baseball players today do not wear stirrups. I played in a kid's baseball league, and I remember how official seeming and functional stirrups seem to be, despite the fact that, you know, with contemporary sock technology, they are rendered essentially functionalists. But it seems that the romance is gone by the time you get to the big leagues.
我想对于许多人来说，包括我自己，这就是我们想到棒球运动员时脑海中浮现的形象。有趣的是，在周刊杂志《纽约客》的版面上，他们刊登了许多以棒球为主题的漫画，他们的漫画家几乎无一例外地把棒球运动员描绘成穿着蹬脚袜的样子，尽管今天大多数真正的棒球运动员并不穿蹬脚袜。我曾在一个儿童棒球联盟打过球，我记得蹬脚袜看起来是多么具有官方感和实用性，尽管事实上，你知道的，凭借现代的袜子技术，它们基本上已经失去了实用功能。但当你进入大联盟时，这种浪漫似乎已经荡然无存了。
Yeah. And in fact, there, you know, I've asked players, why do you wear your pants down? And the answer I often get is, it's just so much less work. You know, if you leave your pants down to your shoe tops, you don't, it's lower maintenance, essentially. You don't have to worry about your socks staying up. You don't have to worry that your stirrups are both sort of at the exact same height or level. You don't have to keep looking and checking to make sure that they're just so.
是的。事实上，你知道的，我曾问过球员，你们为什么把裤子放下来？我经常得到的回答是，这样省事太多了。你知道的，如果你把裤子垂到鞋口，你就不需要……基本上维护成本更低。你不用担心你的袜子会不会滑下去。你不用担心你的两只蹬脚袜是否处在完全相同的高度或水平线上。你不需要一直低头检查确保它们恰到好处。
Just like most of us don't when we walk around with, you know, slacks or jeans or whatever with regular pants. If you wear your pants low, you don't really have to worry about what's going on underneath them. And so it's just easier, and I understand that. If there's a villain in the story of baseball, Hozary, that role would be filled by George Hendrick, who played for the Cardinals and A's and some other teams in the 70s and 80s.
就像我们大多数人在穿着休闲裤、牛仔裤或其他普通裤子时不会去操心的一样。如果你把裤子穿得很低，你真的不需要担心它们下面发生了什么。所以这样更简单，我能理解这一点。如果棒球长袜历史中有一个反派的话，这个角色将会由乔治·亨德里克扮演，他在70年代和80年代曾为红雀队、运动家队和其他一些球队效力。
He's now the first base coach of the Tampa Bay race. He's the one that's most often credited or blamed as the most influential player in the move towards long pants. And he liked to wear his pants down toward his ankles, which by today's standards is pretty tame, but by the standards of the era he played in was seen as radical. He showed very, very little of his socks or stirrups, and some people thought it looked weird or it looked dumpy or it didn't look dignified or whatever, but there were other players who thought it looked different and therefore innovative and therefore cool. What major league baseball players, a sock style, do you most admire?
他现在是坦帕湾光芒队的一垒教练。他最常被归功于或归咎于，是推动长裤风潮中最具影响力的球员。他喜欢把裤子一直垂到脚踝附近，以今天的标准来看这相当保守，但在他效力的那个时代标准来看，这被视为激进。他露出的袜子或蹬脚袜非常、非常少，有些人觉得这看起来很怪异，或者看起来邋遢，或者看起来不够庄重等等，但也有其他球员觉得这看起来很别致，因此很有创新意识，因而很酷。你最欣赏哪个美国职棒大联盟球员的袜子风格？
At this point, I mean, it's pretty slim pickings in terms of Hojiri heroes nowadays because there aren't many players who wear stirrups to begin with and even fewer who wear stirrups the way I like to see them, like the style I like. The best, I would say, is a pitcher named Josh Outman, which is a great name for baseball, right? Outman, he's a pitcher, he gets the players out. And he wears a real 1970 style of stirrups that I love. A lot of other people don't love it so much, he's number one as far as I'm concerned read Johnson who's an outfielder He wears stirrups in a not too shabby way, but the fact that I I have to search my
到了这个地步，我的意思是，如今在长袜英雄方面选择真的非常有限，因为本来就没有多少球员穿蹬脚袜，而像我这样喜欢看人穿、喜欢那种风格的球员就更少了。最好的，我要说是一个名叫乔什·奥特曼的投手，这名字用来打棒球真是太棒了，对吧？奥特曼（Outman），他是个投手，他三振（out）球员。他穿着一种我非常喜欢的真正的1970年代风格的蹬脚袜。许多其他人并不是那么喜欢它，但在我看来他就是第一名。里德·约翰逊（Reed Johnson），他是一个外野手，他穿蹬脚袜的方式也相当不错，但事实是我必须在我的
Mental database to come up with three or four players. It's just not that great in terms of stirrups now there are other players who do Hike their pants up high and just wear solid color socks and do so pretty nicely. Curtis Granderson, man, he looks great in the uniform. Stephen Strasberg of the Washington Nationals, the young phenom pitcher, does something great called blousing, which means he doesn't just hike his pants up, but he tucks under the cuff in a way where it just sort of blouses out a little bit at the point where he tucks it under instead of just bunching them up the way Alex Rodriguez does, for example.
大脑数据库里搜索一番才能想出三四名球员。现在就蹬脚袜而言，情况真的不太妙。不过还有其他球员确实把裤子高高拉起，只穿纯色袜子，而且穿得相当漂亮。柯蒂斯·格兰德森，天哪，他穿这套制服看起来帅极了。华盛顿国民队的史蒂芬·斯特拉斯堡，这位年轻的现象级投手，做了一件很棒的事，叫做“布劳森”（blousing），这意味着他不仅把裤子高高拉起，而且把裤脚往里塞，塞成了一种在裤脚塞入处稍微向外鼓出一点的形状，而不是像亚历克斯·罗德里格斯那样把裤子胡乱堆在一起。
And that's sort of a lost art blouse in. Jim Tome, who recently retired, slugger, who played for many teams, great, great blouse sir, all-time blouse sir. So there are lots of little elements here to appreciate. There is absolutely no doubt that the final cut of this piece includes you saying Jim Tome, former slugger for the Cleveland Indians. Great blouse sir, excellent, excellent, all-time great blouse sir. Oh man. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Jesse Thorn with Sam Greenspan, Avery Truffleman,
这可以说是“布劳森”的一种失传艺术。吉姆·托梅，最近刚退役的强力打者，曾效力于多支球队，他是个极其出色的“布劳森”大师，史上最佳“布劳森”大师。所以这里有很多值得欣赏的小细节。毫无疑问，这段节目的最终剪辑版里包括了你说出吉姆·托梅的名字，克里夫兰印第安人队的前强力打者。伟大的“布劳森”大师，极其出色、史上最伟大的“布劳森”大师。天哪。《99%隐形》本周由杰西·索恩与萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特拉夫曼共同制作，
Katie Mingle, and me Roman Mars. Jesse Thorn is the host of the NPR program Bullseye, the best pop culture interview program around today. Bull stop. and Mars. iTunes or go to MaximumFun.org. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW in San Francisco and produced of the offices of ArcSign, a group of architects who would never dishonor architectures Hozary Heritage. We have more stories about design all the time on Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr, but we keep our pants rolled to our knees in our stir-up straight at 99bi.org. Radio Tepio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
凯蒂·明格尔以及我罗曼·马尔斯。杰西·索恩是NPR节目《靶心》的主持人，那是当今最好的流行文化访谈节目。停止播送。和马尔斯。iTunes或访问MaximumFun.org。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在ArcSign办公室制作，这是一群永远不会玷污建筑长袜传统的建筑师。我们在Facebook、Twitter和Tumblr上随时提供更多关于设计的精彩故事，但我们在99bi.org上保持裤子卷到膝盖、蹬脚袜笔直。来自PRX的无线电特皮奥。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。